bonjour c'est vanessa paradis pour brut
[Musique]
avait demandé de venir faire une
surprise à jeanne moreau et de chanter
le tourbillon de la vie et elle n'était
pas au courant et on ne savait pas ce
qu'elle allait faire je me souviendrai
toujours je pense je suis rentré sur
scène et c'est une très grande salle et
d'être rentré de mettre concentrer sur
les premières notes à chanter de de
marché j'étais pieds nus sur scène
j'avais un tract d'un que j'avais le
coeur qui bat est tellement fort et j'ai
essayé de contrôler mon adrénaline pour
pouvoir bien chanter la chanson et donc
j'ai gardé les yeux en bas comme ça
jusqu'au je les ai relevé quand je les
ai relevé six tombes et trois dans son
regard gêné vu personne d'autre
je tombais droit dans son regard et
l'annoncé plus lâcher des yeux et elle
s'est levée tout en chantant tout en
souriant et elle s'est approchée de la
scène mais elle n'est pas montée sur
scène elle est restée en bas des marches
comme ça nous aurons je me suis
agenouillé on sait attraper les mains et
on a chanté main dans la main toutes les
deux et c'est un des moments les plus
forts que j'ai vécu sur scène quoi
c'était j'avais l'impression de pourtant
jeudi à genoux sur la scène mais je ne
me présente pas touché le sol quoi
c'était comme un rêve merveilleux très
très fort avec des ddd des sensations
d'une intensité de un bonheur non diluée
quoi c'était fou on peut préparer on
peut on peut répéter mais il ya des
moments de magie comme ça qu'ils qui
s'explique pas c'est celle à col accord
corrélation des éléments qui se rend
compte à un moment très précis et qui
fait que ça ça explose de thé mission
[Musique]
la première fois qu'on s'est vraiment
rencontré c'était pour lui proposer
d'écrire un texte sur mon deuxième album
je n'avais pas 17 ans encore à l'époque
et je jette vraiment beaucoup regardé le
bout de mes chaussures pendant tout le
rendez-vous en écouter les titres
ensemble pour qui les choisissent et je
me souviens nous avait donné des bouts
de papier pour qu'on mette des notes
chacun pour cochons on met des
croissances sont nos préférés et de voir
si on avait les maires et en fait quand
on a fini d'écouter les douze titres
qu'il a dit mais moi je les aime toutes
moi je pourrai pas tout les faire et
c'était c'était incroyable c'était mais
plus bien sûr que tu peux tout les faire
quelle quelle surprise qu'il dit tout
c'était incroyable koala incroyable de
pouvoir avoir la chance de travailler
que lui de passer ou plusieurs mois avec
lui de le voir travailler de le voir
écrire ses textes et puis d'être
ensemble toute la journée les soirs et
en studio a non seulement à travailler
ensemble et à l'entendre raconter tout
un tas d'anecdotes sur sa sur sa vie sa
carrière à lui gt13 très intimidée très
impressionné donc j'ai pu j'ai posé peu
de questions
aujourd'hui jean conjurons jean poserait
beaucoup plus j'ai été trés spectatrice
de lui et il était d'une dune d'une
délicatesse et d'une élégance avec moi
parce qu'on on parle souvent beaucoup de
doutes de 2,15 bourg évidemment après de
parler de son génie d'auteur et musical
mais de de son personnage de 15 par
alors que dans la vie
mais en tout cas moi l'expérience que
j'ai vécue c'était et quelqu'un d'une
cuisine d'une grande délicatesse
extrêmement john coleman et est marié il
ya tellement de choses qui me reviennent
de cette époque tous les taxis mais
peut-être au tout début en fait la
chanson elle l était pas encore le
succès qu'elle était jose à des des
émissions de variétés y en avait une
houle et les gens votaient pour pour
deux chansons celles qu'ils préféraient
et puis ce jour là c'était une mission à
paris et c'était les résultats d'ubs eps
vi ne l'examen compass en fin de
troisième et je me rappelle que j'avais
des copains de classe qui était venu me
voir à cette émission de télé et cette
émission balle à la chanson avec lui et
les gens avaient voté pour la chanson
mais en plus mais quoi par la femme
peuvent est dit et en plus tu as eu une
baisse ce donc c'était c'était un moment
vraiment coincé entre entre vraiment
leur l'adolescence la vie normale et le
début d'un rêve qui commence
être célèbre aussi vite aussi jeune ccc
particulier après avec la djette g
j'ai appris tous les avantages que ça me
donne toutes les possibilités que ça me
donne la chance que ça me donne
après quand on quand on grandit au même
moment fin compost convient son
adolescence est vraiment pas quelque
chose de simple quoi de 2 d'arriver à
savoir qu'ils menaient à cet âge là mais
en plus de le faire devant les yeux du
du du public ccc à cc particulier ce
très fatiguée mais je ne regrette pas
vous repérez y est tous pareils oui